welcome to this video versus never end
okie dokie get a french defence here or
I mean what does he take 125 they takes
mmm yeah I struggle with the Queen move
I really do mostly because I haven't
studied it but I don't like them i QP
position that much either not that it is
a bad position that I could reposition
it just it's not so much not not to look
that much my taste this position yeah
now we get white with the IQ p sorry
very frequently seen position out of the
c3 the soil Queen on d6 is not that
badly place I wonder if I can do
something can I do something a little
bit more active here like 94 or
something maybe this can get google
queen bee aid this is an idea maybe come
on kind of curious a bishop age seven
maybe no it's not really doing much
let's do this I mean have to have the
very naive threat of 90 x 0 of course
but we can try out we can try night XD
form we should be for Bishop a three and
made on h2 coming but of course he will
prevent that maybe I can study retain
them a little bit with the move
so that means 94 rookie former bishop f3
rock these six so it's not working okay
I have to go all of the default anyway
the move t5 now is probably the issue or
cannot take onee three I could have
taken only three by the way that's
probably what I should have done d5 huh
maybe just d5 and yeah of course of
course if i take III is this playable
cheeks III takes you six g1 cakes on I
don't know doesn't seem braid I should
have taken one III huh that was much
stronger
very uncomfortable now I don't know if I
can take maybe I can take but ah it
looks wrong 93 dc-6 is not working okay
what now I think I should take here and
hope that this holds but it looks wrong
it really looks like he has some kind of
winning blow not taking only three was
unforgivable really I should have done
that I think I'm I'm okay after that now
g4 is a bit cheeky but I don't think
really bad now all this piece is on my
king position and there should be
something yeah that looks okay i can
still you have to go to six anyway so
let's play the move and this now ok once
Knight f6
cannot move the night difficult and his
may be threatening look e7 as well
m fantastic we have seven is also on a
huge huge trouble now that just lost
somehow I don't know some some 95 at one
point I don't know that that's lost I
can take rookie seven actually they are
probably can okay just wants to win
without calculating stuff probably time
honey probably it works
95 probably wins yeah seven is just
under so much fire yeah I've got nine f6
but what can you do
that sticky three for God's sake it's so
obvious that after d 5 i'm getting
killed so just have to avoid that Tim
black resigns yeah just that was just
terrible bad terribly bad yeah I just
have to take you three first and this is
a normal position i think i mean it's
it's playable at least I shouldn't lose
right away like we should have six or
something I mean the only move that was
a bit cheeky is that Nyjah for and I
don't think it should be that terrible
oh it is actually bad because of their
direct d5 given by the comp and this is
this is much stronger than what he did
and it actually changes opinion and says
I can play this pollution well okay but
this happened and now yeah I just have
to take and make sure that this is
getting on the board in all some normal
move can I go this is again d fire fire
half maybe Queen Bey maybe that night
you for was just a bit too much can I do
this that's again d 5
yeah sometimes we get tempted by those
who buy those trick moves right like
naija form and like hoping for this and
this is not even working chatter to this
okay so I went back to be 8d five ta
takes and takes their it's just it just
busted probably just busted queen bee
three g6 Quincy three yeah i'm looking
at the CCF six square and okay to dat
could have taken only seven already oh
that's nice actually 9797 bishop seven
need to check mate check check check
check check check check check mate
that's nice mmm yeah it is really no
wonder that there was was even something
better than what he did but it just
winds I cannot do anything rook 87 has
it been tough of it I have played that
actually 95 and tings tings okay this is
given by the computer this is still
somewhat more interesting pigs pigs this
this this and it's not really
interesting at the end I'm losing and
losing they losing the the exchange year
with this enormous enormous d file
situation okay don't really I don't
really remember something like that all
heavy pieces on the D file and I have to
blink first and give the exchange with a
losing position
okay well thanks for watching